what a great finish to a wild-card
weekend Maurice jones-drew
part of the Los Angeles radio broadcast
team and of course a compadre of mine
from NFL Network NFL Media Group good to
see you here sir I'm JD well thank you
for having what you think of when you
saw that man it was weird because I
really felt like Nick Foles it was kind
of like the whole Tebow thing remember
back in the day I would watch you guys
on gameday finally like oh no
tae-bo right Nick Foles but it just
don't have the same rhyme I just felt
like oh is this some belief there's some
system that is something in the universe
that has the Eagles are destined to make
a run and it happens all the time belief
is very powerful and as I said at the
top of the show belief in hope is a
powerful mix when combined also with a
destined feeling well you've already
done it before too right they've already
been through this path so it's it's uh
it's scary I don't I mean weird talk we
were picking again I was like hey
there's no reason for me to pick the
Eagles but I'm just picking them because
I'm not gonna look like a fool twice you
lone wolfed am I thought about pulling
the trigger on it too but I just thought
about how the Bears are making everybody
look ridiculous at the quarterback
position yeah but I don't know what it
is but was it the RPO just slowing down
the rush or the fact that they were able
to send to tight ends but how about my X
Factor is like I like actor scored a
touchdown he also had a huge conversion
in that last final Drive what was it
that the Eagles were able to do that
other teams have not been able to do
against the Bears defense well they have
two tackles that could that they were
pretty much handling Khalil Mack early
in the game Anna Khalil got going later
but they you know after it kind of
settled and they ran the ball well they
were they're mixing up their play calls
and Nick Foles is through to the open
person now he made two mistakes which
you know to pick in the red zone where
you coulda probably went up six three
then the Bears go back but then we have
to talk about that Philly defense that
shut down that that bear is often I mean
they made some big stops and has some
chants where they can make some you know
some big-time plays and drop some pigs
but at the end of the day I've never
seen a team you know they were flying
around from Philly making huge stops and
and crucial stops and Cruiser situations
and that's what kind of changed the game
for him and so what are you
have you ever been in a situation where
your kicker had that happened to him and
obviously Trayvon Hester both a Chris
long was on on twitter twitter and you
can see maybe yeah it looks like it's
hip it so it's not like park he just
yanked it right well what do you say to
a kicker in a situation ah you know I I
play with the great Josh Scobee so we we
had a he made a lot of field goals for
us and some tough times but anytime guys
have had bad games and I think Reggie
Wayne said it best on Twitter like I'd
be the first guy said like here meet me
at the bar he goes to address let's sit
down and have a drink or two and because
it's not his fault and like things
happen in this game you know he made so
many feel those before this he scored
more points and their offense scored
right so he put you in position to be
successful and it's not his fault that
the ball got tipped he'd kicked the ball
perfect he hit it just like he hit the
first one I felt like and you know it
just didn't happen what a game that was
there ago what an absolute game eeeh
we're looking at sure look like it was a
serious matters moved Maurice jones-drew
here on the Rich Eisen show okay do you
but let me ask you your two cents on the
decision John Harbaugh had during the
game yesterday with the Chargers just
putting the bang thing on Lamar Jackson
would you have gone to Joe Flacco not at
all to two reasons one when Joe was the
starting quarterback we were horrible
and we weren't playing well we were
losing games and he gets hurt and Lamar
brings us to the playoffs and then to
we're trying to trade them at the end of
the year and it's a bigger picture that
you have to look at in certain
situations I know a lot of people say
like you have to win now you have to do
this but you've already come out
multiple weeks in advance saying Lamar
is our quarterback and Joe's not playing
anymore
what kind of sign and are you telling
your team when the first sign of
struggle you pull them out trying to put
someone else in we haven't seen that
with anyone else and there's so many
quarterbacks that struggled that
struggled this week and weeks before
this so I wouldn't have done it and at
the end of the day you know their game
plan was so simple and this is another
thing people other think about actually
talked about this was a couple of our
colleagues at the NFL Network is that
all week you put in a specific game plan
for Lamar and Joe wasn't a part of that
Jose
running the read-option and Joe's not
doing any of that so to come out and try
to stick him in and run a different
offense it's gonna be so tough to do
because your players are practiced all
week on a certain offense then you want
them to flip the switch and go somewhere
else you'll have more mistakes but they
already had a whole half of a season
under that offense rights it's not like
isn't it like riding a bike though I
mean hey we're going back to the old
offense you were necessarily because you
you've changed the way you block you've
changed the way you know with the read
option you're letting one guy free all
the time with a regular pro so often
you're not letting guys for you're
blocking everyone so you'll have mental
mistakes there I think with some of the
route combinations you have may work but
at the same time I really don't think it
was Lamar that was the issue
he got sacked seven times and those
sacks weren't like he was holding the
ball forever I mean they were getting
pressure up the middle I got a chance to
speak with Gus Bradley after the game
and what do you say he was like we
wanted to stop the run early and then we
wanted to put our best pass verses
inside to affect the young quarterback
as quick as possible the defensive
coordinator the charges for Jaguars head
coach is that different than what they
did week 16 no question they they had
week 16 they had both their guys outside
they were trying to force Lamar to step
up into the pocket to their rush but
this time they put their bigger guys
outside to keep him in the pocket and
then they put their speed guys inside to
go after their guards and they had they
had success so it was it was a good game
plan you know there's some games where I
think we've all played golf where
there's some days we you know we shoot
in the the low 80s there's some days we
shoot in the 120s it's just it is what
it is yeah but if we shoot in the 120s
were still alive back on the golf course
later on for another 18 even that day if
we want to in the playoffs you're done
did you look back after the 120 though
I'm probably not but I'm gonna push back
on you on this maurice jones-drew even
though I agree with you cuz there's a
ton of people like you Brockman out
there that think that Harbaugh was
derelict of duty by not trying to win
right then and there correct I think so
so what wouldn't putting Flacco in also
create havoc for Gus Bradley's defense
having to try and switch up the way the
Dave practiced all week long I mean I
think again you're still gonna continue
to do what you're doing
you know the run players are gonna
always be the run place I think when
Lamar Jackson and there you have to key
him but when Joe's in there alright
we're not worried about the quarterback
running more we just go back to lists to
stop the run whoever it is Gus Bradley
or or not guys brother Gus Edwards or
Kenneth Dixon we could keel on those
guys it makes it a little easier for
them because remember defense is all
reaction right defense is always we're
gonna see the ball go get ball we're
often so you have to make sure that
everyone's taking the right steps
everyone's you know doing the right
routes Lamar throws a different ball
than Joe Flacco so that's going to be
different to wide receivers and tight
ends it's a lot of little things that I
really feel like people don't understand
but again you know I understand I
understand why people would say go back
to Joe Flacco I didn't I firmly didn't
believe Joe Flacco was that good in the
very beginning so I don't know what he
would have done in this situation to
kind of change what was going on Maurice
jones-drew here on the Rich Eisen show
you were in the green room for the
opening of the program what would you
think of my so-called take that jason
garrett doesn't get the credit he
deserves for the way the cowboys are
playing yeah again cuz well you got them
said Jerry Jones did I get everything
right because he's a GM he's the owner
he's the cat Dallas Cowboys and so Jason
Garrett definitely deserves some credit
one for you know keeping that team
together through some situations where
we everyone from Alice I was like they
should be tanking right now it's over
especially since if I imagine if you put
blood in the water that the coach might
be fired then the locker room can intern
yeah yeah he did a phenomenal job with
that and then I think on you know there
was a lot of times where throughout the
season we didn't see dak Prescott use
his legs everyone's like let him run let
him run right and in third and 14 you
you you have the you know the fortitude
to call a quarterback draw and he takes
it almost to the end zone that's
something that we haven't seen and then
they use that multiple time they did a
quarterback sweep one time so they're
being more creative in certain
situations and it really comes down to
that week 16 game where they they did
the risk/reward keeping them in the
whole time and rest in their offensive
line and Zeke and then him having the
confidence after pulling that out and
you saw it this weekend so now you
seeing the way the Cowboys played again
the only home team only division winner
to win this weekend all that said I'm
looking at you now as a Rams analyst
being around this team your choice for a
divisional opponent is a Seattle team
that you'd have to beat for third time
be a team and the Bears that put the
bang thing on you albeit in Chicago in a
cold-weather situation and have to try
and beat them or see a Cowboys team
that's coming in you've not seen them
they haven't seen you they got the team
they wanted right
if and if you give them in a quiet
moment um I think they'd probably
probably be more comfortable playing
Seattle e'en because you know them and
really you you even have a medium a
third time yeah I don't think it's that
once you beat a team twice you kind of
more confident going in I do remember
this though last year going to Dallas
with the Rams and playing that game in
Dallas which the teams are similar
there's a little different but not too
much but you sound like Jerry Jones
there by the way no not similar like
they maybe they look like each other
they play like I mean both teams are the
same from last year so the Dells
probably the same the right I'm saying
but there came a time in that game in
the second half that they had to stop
the run because his ego was just running
all over them and they they buckled down
they did it and then the offens got
going they were able to make a run and
win in that win that game in Dallas
which was huge I think the players that
were there still have that confidence
that they can do that but they have to
stop the run this is the playoffs you
you can't allow a team to run for 150
200 yards in a game and expect to win
and it's gonna be tough for that offense
is why the I know you I saw it earlier
you're gonna talk to big Whitworth here
and he'll talk about me the Dallas
Cowboys our defensive line they do a
phenomenal job of getting to the ball
and getting pressure you have some fast
linebackers I can run around but you
know I think the addition of CJ Anderson
is going to gonna kind of be a big big
deal for the this Rams offense because
Todd Gurley is such a home run hitter
Longstride ur phenomenal back out of the
backfield but they need that guy that
can just get you the tough two or three
and I think that's where CJ Anderson
comes what a fascinating matchup this is
from the fact that there's Wade Phillips
yeah okay who is bounced for Jason
Garrett
well that was long long time ago yeah
Jason Garrett was an interim coach
before getting the gig because they
fired Wade in the middle of a season
there's Wade Phillips now on the other
sideline trying to coordinate the
defense against this offense that Jerry
Jones said much
everyone's enjoyment earlier this year
before Amari Cooper came on like hey
we've got tavon we've got ourselves a
young right quarterback and yeah we got
ourselves a running back that's kind of
a bell cow that can do everything like
Todd Gurley we're not too far off from
the Los Angeles Rams everybody made fun
of them and now here they come with a
Morey Cooper that's different from last
year now it is that that's the big
difference that the big difference is
Amari Cooper then also having tape on
because say Vaughn was in this system
for two years so he understands what
what you know kind of the plays they
like to do so you know you're gonna have
a double agent mess situation which is
always good you nervous no I don't play
anymore I did I just caught a second
then are you concerned who I'm I'm
always concerned in the playoffs because
it's only one game this isn't the NBA
this isn't the MLB where you have a
series of games it's only one game so
you have to be on your game the whole
time that's why it's so fun and
fascinating to see this but I'm always
concerned never nervous always concerned
though because you want to make sure you
know being a part of this organization
and being a part of this this this team
and being able to kind of voice what's
going on throughout their journey if you
know if you're not on your a-game come
Saturday night it's a problem ask the
poll question if Maurice jones-drew
Chris Brockman despite you your
workspace falling apart around what do
you got which home team in the
divisional round home team this weekend
in the most trouble mjd Patriots Chiefs
Rams Saints oh that's it cuz I'm scared
of the Colts too
I'm terrified of the Colts both succeeds
huh I am both it's just I don't know
what it is what scares you about the
Colts they can score with anybody and
they can run the ball and their
offensive line is is right now I feel
like it's playing the best out of any
offensive line in the National Football
League and then your defense I you know
there's some guys we don't know their
names and they're not household names
but they're there making plays you go
into Houston and blank them pretty much
into the fourth quarter I mean I mean
Lamar Miller disappeared I mean just
absolutely disappeared and that's
exactly what that mean
deshaun Watson leading the team in
rushing yeah sitting back there like a
sitting duck when you knew they had to
throw it down 20
nothing I mean that thing was a rap
pretty much Brockman you tweeted out
this this give me a three score game I
told you to pace yourself and then five
minutes later after they picked off
deshaun Watson I'm like okay you can
pick up the pace a little bit on your
take well the other thing is it was
something they did in in the playoff
game I twitch I call play all came a
week 17 minutes of titans where they
went on to 80 yard drives or something
like that right it was two long drives
back-to-back the Colts the Colts right
that to me is the scariest thing you can
see because you I'd rather have a quick
strike offense because if they stumbled
and they feel the pressure the culture
never feel pressure because they're
comfortable being methodical going
downfield getting it three four five
tough yards and then being able to you
know score in the red zone we talked
about that on air it's scoring in the
red zone is huge and I want to say their
fifth in the National Football League
and scoring in the red zone cuz you
again field goals aren't gonna help you
yeah we saw the Houston Texans get stuck
in the red zone and and you know they
went for it a couple of times instead of
kicking a field goal which I get I
understand but you have to score
touchdowns and that's what they do well
they make sure you should be shorter to
him a couple of yards
are you sure them they were actually 290
yards it's even crazier so I let you
talk it out like Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire contestant but I need an
answer which team is in the most trouble
this coming up weekend in your best
opinion Maurice jones-drew I'm gonna say
the Patriots okay wisely we had a
conversation in the back and I yeah I
really appreciate his confidence as a
Patriots fan but I do have to say this
the Chargers play phenomenal on the road
and they've been in some tough games
some tough situations and I don't
again the Patriots have their back right
there they found a way but they've
stumbled along the way and they're
running the ball well can they continue
to run the ball well against this team
that's done a great job stopping the run
and Philip Rivers and I just think
Philip Rivers those guys there they're
excited to play man they think this is
their their year five inches of snow hit
the ground does that change your opinion
cuz that's the forecast for for Sunday's
divisional Sunday kickoff that we're
taking everyone up to kickoff to on game
day yeah yeah no I'm not concerned at
all because they're gonna run the ball
and I think if Melvin Gordon's banged up
they have Justin Jackson who we talked
to who I talked about that's your x-ray
and he didn't play what
but they made me for the division right
I don't know right get all your X
Factor's right exactly but I think they
have enough backs and they had their
offensive line they do a really good job
of going forward and you have a veteran
quarterback and so it's gonna be
exciting to see because the last time I
want to say the Chargers went to
Foxborough either they beat him or it
was a close game I have that information
right here it was it was last season it
was week 8 of last season down by 8
points at the New England 23 with a
second ago Phillip threw an interception
so but the Patriots out gain the
Chargers through the air
three hundred some-odd two hundred
some-odd 190 somewhat but look that's
last year's last year they say this year
as you point out it's a different
Patriots team but I just think it's the
middle I could just see Andrew Luck
going into Kansas City one and dunning
the Chiefs B as every single first time
quarterback in the playoffs yes this
weekend lost
Owen three mahomes is a TBD and they won
and done him and then all of a sudden
New England gets the AFC Championship
game in their house and I can also see
the Eagles going into New Orleans and
winning that game and the Rams get a
home playoff game as do maybe the
Cowboys for the NFC champion you know if
someone once said our that was written
on Twitter there's an opportunity if big
if the charges go into Foxborough win
Colts beat the Chiefs you have a AFC a
championship game here in LA and then if
the Rams happened in the Eagles you have
two in LA and I that would be crazy
I've heard though that the league if
that happened if it ever happened in the
same stadium they would move it to
Monday they move one of the games to
Monday they'd have a Sunday in a Monday
championship game I don't know if they
do that because of I mean Carson and the
downtown Los Angeles area are so far
apart that you'd be able to maybe
logistically pull it off but it's
possible that Los Angeles is your home
to championship Sunday and it's
absolutely feasible it's wide open it's
so exciting how open okay so I'll say it
I to Andrew Whitworth below at the top
of the next same draft class - as you
yeah we was drafted a couple I won't say
like ten spots before me oh so does that
mean he wore number 22 no
is that I wore 32 cuz all 32 teams
passed he couldn't you should've well he
should beware 32 as well okay good to
see you I'm JD good to see you bet great
job this weekend - it was great fun
hanging with you know hope to see it are
you on the air next Sunday to have to
talk to the producers hopefully Richard
okay Richard is a cow I let him to come
back but you know and I thought I won
the exo show no it was but it was like
the little cheap shot at they kind of
like wrestling the people in charge
decide who wins you understand yeah
alright Andrew Whitworth 55 v over I'll
pick Maurice your idea there you go the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience